[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
being bomb who joins us now the host of
the paul feinbaum show on espn radio
paul is part of espn's exclusive
coverage of the 2022 college football
playoff national title game kicking off
next monday january 10th at 8 eastern
paul
is it a good thing that georgia and
alabama are meeting again for a national
championship
well you know dan i'm contractually
obligated not to say anything negative
um but
and and by the way keep that in mind for
the next question or the one after that
as well
i heard the previous segment yeah um
i doubt this is not a good thing for
college football and and i say that
because i i think the whole idea
for fans is that you want to see
something different you want to see
something interesting you would like to
see
east versus west north versus south so
seeing a game that we saw
five weeks ago
is not probably going to light up the
bars in manhattan uh or in los angeles
but that's you know what can you do
about it there's only one way to try to
get around that this and that's to
expand the playoff it may not work but
uh you know the sec seems to like four
frankly they like two right now
yeah when people say well if you expand
the playoffs you're still going to get
george against alabama which could be
true
but you do get more fan bases involved
in this and that you're playing
meaningful games meaningful bowl games
where if you win that bowl game you go
to another bowl game there
it's just a question of are we still
going to get back to alabama and georgia
or you know is it going to be one or two
sec teams no matter what
well the whether you get back to alabama
or georgia i don't think is the most
important point the point is that you
have a build up i mean why are we
watching football tonight or saturday
and sunday to see you know whether you
get a buy to see whether you get a good
seed and to me that's where the nfl has
it over college football the college
football season you have championships
saturday on december 3rd and then it
goes to sleep yeah
for four weeks and we wake up on new
year's eve and then we're right back
asleep again because the playoff games
have been a total disaster
the stats prove that i won't waste your
time on it uh and and then and then so
you you go to bed knowing who's playing
in the national championship game and
you wake up and guess what you've got
all-day football uh of games that
didn't matter uh in the margins
and but before i before we move on dan
let me remind you i think it's tuesday
night this week we have lsu and kansas
state and some bowl somewhere
exclusively on espn
i'll watch it but i didn't even thank
you for the heads up
program reminder what is cincinnati's
loss going to mean for other non-power
fi the next team
i think the fact that
they played a better game than michigan
helps uh i mean you i mean i was i was
there and it was an interesting game for
a while uh it was not a complete
annihilation um
i don't think that committee next year
if they have a similar situation is
going to say you know what cincinnati
lost
uh by three touchdowns let's keep them
out uh i i think what it tells me and
unfortunately it's not telling the
people that matter is that we really do
need to expand this i i felt like it was
a great experience for cincinnati i i i
liked having somebody new in there and i
think luke fickle you know is one of the
premier coaches but
you know the problem the problem isn't
cincinnati
it's alabama because alabama does this
to everyone
they beat notre dame by by 17 last year
even though it was really a 24 point
game they beat everyone by three
touchdowns so i think we're we're
obviously blaming the wrong team i think
the thing to do is to move alabama maybe
to the nfc south and we'll have a much
better playoff every year but i wondered
i had chuckled a little bit when i was
reading some articles that this is the
best coaching job that saban's ever done
i mean the last i looked alabama still
has the heisman trophy winner they've
got
two really good wide receivers they got
a first round draft pick at lineback i
mean
that's not a bad team to have if you're
gonna have one of your best coach it's
not like belichick after brady left you
know this is he's the cupboard wasn't
bare there so
did saban do his best coaching job this
year because maybe we're not familiar
with these players
i think i think i i used to be a
newspaper columnist stan as you remember
and and you're just trying to come up
with something new to say about that
saber uh
it was it was 15 years ago today i was i
was doing local radio and tv in
birmingham he arrived from miami
and all the pundits said he wouldn't
last so i mean we are struggling to find
new things to say
and and i i mean i i i came on right
after the game on the honor network and
it was rather boring okay nick saban
going to another
national championship in case you've
lost count this is his 10th national
championship game whether it's bcs or
or college football playoff and i mean
you really uh i think i mean maybe i
missed something on schevsky but but
john wooden's the only guy that's come
close to that i think in in the two
major sports
and i i it was he did a good job but you
know it's three straight years with
three different starting quarterbacks
now two of those guys uh are starting in
the nfl right now and the one the
quarterback before that starting in the
nfl and and this year's quarterback is
only the heisman trophy winner so uh
yeah i think that's probably uh you're
overreaching the or overshooting the
runway to make that statement i know
that you're on scholarship there with
the mothership so you might choose your
words carefully but i
didn't agree with kirk kerb street and
desmond howard saying that the players
who opt out of the bowl games don't love
football
your thoughts
um i'm sorry dan there's some
interference here
[Laughter]
yeah i i think you said it best when uh
when you said that you know maybe the
overnight flight from miami to uh
pasadena uh clouded his judgment um
i i i'm i agree with you uh i i think
these players uh have the right and
should do anything they want and and
your point was the best one if the
coaches can bail the players should be
able to do what whatever they want and i
i think trying to you know look at the
way it used to be uh versus the way it
is now is is is wrong i mean we have a
playoff now uh there wasn't a playoff
when i was in school when you were in
school or when when
when kirk was in school and yeah these
guys give everything if they don't want
to play in a ball game good for them uh
i mean whole teams didn't want to play
in bowl games this year forget players i
thought it was ironic dan and don't
think i'm trying to obfuscate here even
though i am that uh that
none of the major ball games got
canceled just the ones prior to new
year's eve uh now i know the gator ball
had a had a change of uh team because
texas a m couldn't make it but at least
they were nice about it they they gave
the they gave the host committee a week
and a half to find a team with a uh what
what they have a five and seven record
so that was really benevolent of them
it's great to talk to you as always and
uh
[Laughter]
i i hope i didn't get you in trouble
here
um i don't know why i'm getting a call
from lee fitting right now but uh
dan it's always a pleasure happy new
year i'll leave you with this who wins
the national title game
i am leaning toward the the man of the
moment that's nick saban the greatest
coach in history and the guy who i read
this morning in u.s today usa today did
his best coaching job
[Laughter]
thank you buddy that's uh thank you very
much fine bomb host of the paul feinbomb
show on espn radio the voice of the scc